it's great to welcome to the program
today Tracy Walder who is a former staff
operations officer at the CIA's
Counterterrorism Center and a special
agent at the FBI's Los Angeles field
office and author of the newly published
book the unexpected spy which we are
going to be linking to a Tracy so great
to talk to you thank you so much for
having me on the show so to start with
what were you doing at the time that you
stopped at a recruiting table for the
CIA and this entire career path sort of
became a possibility for you so at that
particular time I was a junior in
college majoring in history wanted to be
a high school history teacher but I also
had an interest sort of in the world and
in government in politics so I was that
particular day I was taking my resume
with me to the USC internship center to
apply for an internship in Washington DC
and what is the initial conversation
like with the CIA
recruiting person that happened to be
hanging around there collecting resumes
so I remember bits of my initial
conversation with him the first one was
you know am I really qualified for this
job I'm a history major I think I
thought maybe I had to have a different
background than that and he said no that
lots of different majors bring lots of
different skills to the table so that
was sort of my initial conversation with
him was there any indication at that
early stage about the specifics of the
type of work you might end up doing no
um I actually remember asking him that
question
you know what would I be doing and he
said that that really wasn't up to him
that was up to where the agency had
openings and vacancies and where they
would ultimately place you so talk us
through the process that starts as you
decide that this is something that you
at least potentially interested in so I
gave him my resume and then he said that
you know that you might expect to call
you know within the month about sort of
a large group interview that you would
go to and I'd say about two weeks later
I received a phone call asking me to
come to a large group interview that
was occurring started in the ballroom of
a hotel in LA so I did that and then
after that you are sort of vetted and
they decide whether or not the movie
want to the next process and that
process was flying you out to the DC
area and you would conduct sort of a
whole battery of tests a physical
background kind of conversation with you
battery of math type testing
psychological type testing and then you
go polygraph exam after that if you
passed that and they decide to move
forward with you then they begin sort of
the personal background investigation
and that's where someone actually comes
out to California where I was and
conducts the background check were you
worried at the time not not from like a
criminal perspective or anything like
that but were you worried at the time
that there might just be something in
your life up until that point that might
be disqualifying for me no I had always
been sort of a really good I'm a rule
follower I've always been a rule
follower it's just kind of in my nature
and who I was my sibling on the other
hand was not so who's just we were two
kind of different ends of the spectrum
so I couldn't think of anything in my
life in fact um my first polygraph test
came back as inconclusive because my
pellagra fur had a really hard time
believing that you know a 20-year old
sorority girl had never used drugs in my
life and and I still have it they
selling its truth too difficult to
believe in other words yes I guess my
squeaky-clean background sort of worked
against me so at what point does the
counterterrorism path open to you so
really right away you know we have to
remember that this is this is pre 9/11
right and so the agency looks like a
very different place at that time the
centers that they had so the
counter-proliferation Center
counterterrorism center
counter-narcotics center would not
necessarily the most desirable places to
be everyone sort of wanted to work in
the Russia group or the Latin American
group because those were those like
hotbed issues and so they sort of put
people that had like
broader understanding so history majors
English majors those kinds of things
into these centers and so really right
away that's where I was placed and there
were a lot of young people there there
with me what was the atmosphere at that
time about the value of the work that
was being done again given that it was
pre 9/11 I would say the atmosphere is I
think I've always felt valued you know
by the seventh floor which is I guess
the administrative section of the CIA I
think we always felt valued you know at
that time believes Clinton was still
president and he was was very much
interested in sort of the geopolitics of
Somalia and sort of the Arabian
Peninsula so I never necessarily felt
undervalued maybe if I was there ten
years prior to that you know perhaps
that might be a different story
so after 9/11 does what you're working
on change yes so I had been doing a lot
of you know kind of targeting looking at
individuals who were in the terrorist
training camps that we had in
Afghanistan monitoring those and because
I had been doing that for a little bit
just before September 11th I was read
into I guess what you would call today
your conventional drone warfare program
and so I started doing that really eat
it right after September 11th for about
three or four months and then after that
I was moved into the counterterrorism
centers weapons of mass destruction
group so as many people remember there
was a case made by what was then the
Bush administration for going into Iraq
and many of us remember the
presentations made by : Powell with
annotated graphs and charts and building
the case that either Saddam had the
weapons of mass destruction or had them
at some point and was going through
efforts in order to hide them or make it
seem as though maybe he does not you
actually write about creating a chemical
chart that was later altered and am I
correct that it actually became part of
that intelligence case that was
presented at some point
yes you are correct so you have to
remember our tasking as the
counterterrorism centers weapons of mass
destruction group was to recruit assets
or information about al-qaeda trying to
procure we were tracking small-scale
poisons so things like ricin brought two
line of different poisons and so that
was our tasking really our task II was
not to find WMDs in Iraq that was sort
of the Iraq group was a different group
but for us the way we kept track of our
targets um was through a chart even
though we're on the operation side
there's still kind of analysis that has
to take place you know in terms of
knowing who is where and why they're
there and so we had this huge chart with
a guy named Zarqawi at the top who we
believed was sort of the person tasked
by bin Laden to procure these things and
then serve as henchmen
I guess underneath in various stages and
we have that chart up on our cubicle
wall just for us to visually keep keep
straight I mean one day a member of the
administration had come down which was
actually not unusual at that point in
time is quite a heated time and asked
for a copy of the chart which I mean I
don't think we thought anything about
that it wasn't unusual so we gave them
the copy of the chart and the chart was
originally titled SAR cows poison
network but Colin Powell used that chart
on the floor of the UN and it was
retitled Iraq WMD terrorist connections
now now with you I want to make sure I
understand this so so far it seems that
the chart you've described does not
relate to Iraq it relates to al-qaeda
so at what point does that right so so
and then they use that chart to connect
to Iraq in a way that you had not
connected that's correct so for us with
Zarqawi who was and I'll just keep
referring back to him cuz he was on you
know the top of that chart um you know
for us we knew that he had kind of bit
up in the Kurdish territory of Iraq but
that wasn't unusual that was sort of a I
guess it was a no-man's land but it was
sort of the wild wild west
Saddam Hussein you know didn't like the
Kurds we know this historically and you
know it was a sort of a lawless region
so he had used that area that I guess
transit in between Iran on in some other
places we had no reason to think though
that there was any nexus of him
necessarily being there other than him
using it as sort of a transit location
so we didn't think anything other than
that
at some point in everything as this is
developing you end up with access
directly to George W Bush and George
Tenet at the time can you talk about how
that came to be so that was before all
the war I'm sorry I have the timing
wrong so the poisons and in chart
situation was a little later in my
career
um I was working with them directly uh
when I was doing the sort of more
Afghanistan Predator stuff because it
was so new um they were always in our
office with us pretty much all the time
because they wanted to see you know what
was going on and in my book it's like
this interesting dichotomy because I
talk about Bush in sort of two different
ways like how he handled Afghanistan and
then how he handled a rock and you know
what I think is good and what I think is
bad and so it's this kind of meet in the
middle that I guess I had to find in
between were you an outlier in some of
the work that you were doing at the CIA
in being a woman and in being a younger
woman as well in particular when it
comes to whether it's the debriefing
that sometimes takes place of
individuals or or in anyway I mean what
was that experience sort of like for you
so I did do debriefings I talk about
that in my book I had no issues being a
younger woman in fact a lot of my female
colleagues were around the same age as I
am give or take a year to I never felt
out of place or not wanted or not valued
or not that people thought I could do
the job I mean the way I was treated was
very much you know this this is your
thing you go talk to the person um so I
never felt that way there but again
that's my experience I'm sure there's
other women that have other experiences
and in terms of the experience in
experiences doing the debriefing of
terrorists what what was that experience
like um that was a surreal experience I
don't think I ever thought that I would
come face to face at least in my life
with a terrorist ever I don't remember
ever being scared
um and I remember really happy to find
my way in terms of what tactic I would
use to sort of talk with him and I guess
mine was I don't want to say good cop
because I wasn't you know over overly
kind to them but um he it was more
conversational I guess in tone and I
learned a lot about being a Jew how much
I remember asking you know why do you
hate Americans and they said you know we
don't hate Americans we hate the Jews
but you're not Jewish we can tell you
that and I kind of had this moment do I
tell you or do I not tell you I chose
not to yes I I'm not with terrorists but
that's an experience I've had many
dozens of dozens of times in my life I
can tell you we've been speaking with
Tracy Walter we are gonna go to a break
on the TV and radio show but we will
continue our conversation with her and
you can find the full conversation on
our on our YouTube channel
so eventually Tracy you actually move
from the CIA to the FBI which strikes me
number one is interesting because it
gives you specific insight into some of
these now known tensions between the two
agencies it's also something that if I
recall correctly was not readily
believed by some of the people you were
training with it at the FBI I mean was
it that unusual that at the FBI they
said she was from the CIA that doesn't
even sound quite right well that's what
I find so weird about the whole
situation was that you know the FBI had
to come to CIA to interview me and
conduct my background investigation so
there wasn't like some mystery about you
know where I worked this wasn't you know
a strange thing um yes I I think that it
is viewed as perhaps unusual I mean even
I've tried to find lately women who have
worked on the operations of both sides
and of both organizations and I really
haven't
so yes I guess it's weird but that
doesn't mean that it gives them the
right to sort of debase what I did in
and where I had come from and what is it
about I mean I'm interested in the
internal culture here when the FBI when
you're FBI colleagues learned and then
believed eventually that you did come
from the CIA how did that impact their
perception of you and the work that you
were doing or would soon be doing at the
FBI it's hard to know what that was
because I came from the CIA or because I
was a female
I don't not that I'll ever know why it
was hard because I had come from the CIA
where I was loved treated very well had
great relationships with my colleagues
won many awards so I just assumed it
would be the same way I mean when I
wasn't that was very surprising to me
and so it's hard to know if it's because
it came from the CIA or if it's because
I'm a very very feminine woman that is
hardest thing so at the CIA you said
that many of your colleagues were women
roughly your age that that changed at
the FBI I was definitely the youngest in
my class by far on the FBI does have a
minimum age which I believe is 25 and I
would have been 26 so like right you
know it's right at the cusp of that I
might say the average age was probably
about thirty two ish somewhere around
that so yeah I mean I was younger um but
what was interesting is even when I
worked at the CIA and I had older female
colleagues you know I'm talking you know
probably in their sixties kind of at the
towards the ends of their career I was
never treated badly by them either and
so you know there's so many factors I'm
just I'm not entirely sure which one it
was sure no that makes sense in terms of
the work that you did at the FBI number
one where did where did you specialize
there and how did it feel to be doing
that versus what you had been working on
in counterterrorism at the CIA so yeah I
mean it was initially surprising to me
that they placed me in Chinese
counterintelligence I had assumed that
I'd be working counterterrorism simply
because that's what I had done
for the past five years or so of the
agency but I didn't approach it with a
negative attitude I'm kind of the person
that's like well let's just go find out
more about this and you know it I was
looking for it was surprised but still
looking forward to it so I was placed it
in the Chinese counterintelligence
school and it turns out that they had
put me there not because of my expertise
but because of my security clearance
that I had at the CIA when you think
back to the work you did at both
agencies do you have a strong intuitive
sense that what you did at one versus
the other was of more sort of direct
value or more rewarding in some sense
that's a really good question and I'm
not sure that I can give you a fair
answer because at the FBI my impact or
my thought of any impact that I had is
severely clouded by my treatment right
as a female so I don't know that that's
fair in terms of like face to face
impact yeah the FBI definitely had more
because you're dealing so much with with
victims and families and those kinds of
things at the CIA I felt like I had a
tremendous impact but it's much more
nebulous and more more broad when um
when we hear about the sometimes lack of
playing nice as it's called between some
intelligence agencies and obviously with
the current president there's been a lot
of conflict also between the agencies
and the White House as well do you have
any kind of particular insight from the
time you spent at both agencies and
relating to the people in the White
House about what is going on if there
are particular dynamics that really vary
from administration to administration or
if there's something about the structure
of these agencies that leads to this
type of conflict so I think it's like a
two two pronged answer I think the first
one is I worked there under Bush and I
worked there under Clinton so obviously
two ideologically different presidents
both of them kept Tennant as the head of
the CIA and I would say both of them you
know regardless of what you think
politically I'm just reporting how I
felt
treated intelligence in a except for
later on in a rather
a political manner you know the
Intelligence Agency was not there just
to serve them or you know dig up dirt
both of them read the pub the
presidential Daily Brief both of them
would have questions about the
presidential Daily Brief so I
appreciated that um in working there my
colleagues were very apolitical I mean
we just didn't I think now unfortunately
what we're seeing is that it's the
intelligence community's being used as
as protective arm for the president and
I think that is a huge problem
regardless of where you stand
politically I wish people could sort of
get politics out of their mind and just
kind of look back and see why this is
negative I think from why these two
agencies dislike each other so much has
to do with their missions
the CIA is an intelligence gathering
organization that's all they do that is
their mission the FBI is a
law-enforcement organization and I think
the CIA because they're dealing with
human assets that's a different security
clearance and the FBI gets their
feathers ruffled when the CIA says oh I
can't tell you that and so I think
that's where you it's this clash of ego
that sort of happens and that's a huge
problem I think we need to sort of step
back from ourselves and our egos and
realize that this is sometimes for the
greater good of national security
last thing I wanted to ask you about now
that you are out of that world are you
are there things that still affect you
from it in terms of whether you think
about your personal security on a day to
day basis or in any other way
so I'm there's been a kind of three
different things the first one was I had
to un testify in front of the Inspector
General about torture and things like
that when I was already out of the
agency so you know clearly there was an
issue yes uh the second one was I
believe it was a data breach or data
hack in the Office of Personnel
Management and they had all of our
information um people who had worked
there and then the third is since the
release of my book there's been a lot of
people that really don't like that I
worked for the CIA
um and that I threatened me
um yelled at me screamed at me called me
a murderer until now you know our house
is under close watch from our local
police department so that's been an
issue when you say people have yelled at
you people have found you in the real
world and yelled at you yes so you know
I'd have a book signing events people
will yell at me there or how people
follow me to private events held at me
there it's quite interesting and when
you say that there they're mad you work
that the CIA like what does that even
mean they they're mad well and I and I'm
not I don't mean to be political I'm at
I'm actually an independent politically
but um what had happened was is
unfortunately my books release came out
at the same time as there was a hashtag
trending abolish the CIA and it was
because of some things I think from the
Bernie Sanders time that he had served
and people were showing up to chant that
and call me a murderer for have working
there for housing oh yeah Wow it's an
incredible story we've been speaking
with Tracy Walder her book is the
unexpected spy which we are linking to
Tracy I can't tell you how much I
appreciate your time and you sharing
your story with us today thank you so
much for having me I really enjoyed this
very much